if you just give me a new law a new law
why doesn't the president conf fix this
he already has the existing law and now
I'd like to give Bill a little credit
because on his main program real time uh
bill is getting it when it comes to the
Democrat nonsense around the border the
fact that right this very moment the
president who only weeks ago his entire
clown Administration was saying there's
no crisis of border now they're all
acknowledging there's a crisis at the
border but they're pretending still that
Biden can't just fix it right now well
bill called him out on that part two of
the acting is is is Joe Biden saying you
know what if you just give me a new law
a new law why doesn't the president conf
fix this he already has the existing
laws
border I need a piece of paper from
Congress to deal with the Border no you
already have that that's right that's
right all right so now again bill you
are supporting the guy and you voted for
the guy last time so you have to think
about that I suppose but that is good he
is saying to his liberal audience that
we want to get there and they some of
them get there in slowmo he's saying to
them Biden can fix this freaking thing
right now it's on Biden it's not on the
Republicans but speaking of Republicans
Republican leader Mike Johnson uh he
tweeted out that clip and he wrote this
even Bill Mah gets it President Biden
absolutely has the authority right now
to fix the catastrophe he's created at
the border and that is absolutely true
right you guys know it one of those very
few things that the Fed ederal
government is supposed to do is protect
the Border not only are they not
protecting the border now they are in a
fight with the states specifically Texas
but it's going to come to all the border
states and then it'll come to the
non-border states too when they are
trying to do something about the Border
because the federal government will not
do their
job